so this is our very first GP review of
2020 and it's gonna be an interesting
one
you see back at CES AMD announced the RX
5600 XD which is priced at $280 and
supposed to sort of slot between the RX
5500 XD 8 gigabyte and the arks 5700 in
their lineup they showed some specs and
had a few performance slides that showed
it beating the nvidia gtx 1660 TI by a
pretty convincing margin and that means
it could also go toe-to-toe against CRT
X 2060 so guess what happened Nvidia
decided to lower their price up there
our TX 2060 to $300 but good luck
actually finding one for that price also
things take a little bit of an
interesting turnaround for AMD because
they pulled a last-minute trigger on
everyone who knew the specs would be
5600 XD because last week they rolled
out an official bios that increased bore
power core frequencies and memory speeds
and the effect on performance is pretty
drastic so we needed to scramble since
our 5600 xt testing was already done and
I'm pretty sure Nvidia is scrambling to
at the moment since they have nothing
that can compete also there's more to
that and of course we have to get into
the benchmarks but first a quick message
from our sponsor the land cool -
enclosure by Lian Li is the $89 case to
beat that packs a lot of features with
user-friendly assembly and high
performance functionality in mind like
do OTG side panels with separate shower
doors for easy access to the included
hard drive cage the interior is well
equipped for cable management on a ATX
motherboards once you flip the cable bar
while the back section is covered with
panels for best visuals the top is also
air flow ready with multi Lane fan
installation but this front fan bracket
is next level with four positions
available to suit your cooling style
check out the Lanco to buy lien lee down
below alright so let's start things off
with the specs since even without the
new BIOS the arcs 3600 xt was a pretty
interesting card basically it uses the
same Navi 10 GPU core which is also
found on the arcs 5700 and it even has
the same number of stream processors
texture units and ro piece the real
differences where lower clock speeds and
892 bit memory interface instead of a
256 bit one
on the RX 5700 some people thought that
pricing was a little bit too high at
$280 since even though the 5700 XD
officially cost 350 you could pick it up
for between 320 and 340 but then the new
BIOS happened and what did that do well
the power limit was increased by about
10 watts the game clock which is where
the GPU will spend most of its time
jumped up by almost 200 megahertz the
boost clock got a nice bump as well but
the biggest surprise was the memory that
shot up from 12 gigabits per second to
14 gigabits per second not only that but
Amy's board partners like sapphire XFX
and power color are taking things even
further with their overclocked versions
so let's take a look at this for example
this is the sapphire pulse 5600 XT it's
game clock goes even further to 16 15
megahertz and for those of you keeping
track that's to 40 megahertz higher than
the arcs 5600 XT was supposed to hit B
boosts clock hits up to 17 50 megahertz
and those pecs get really really close
to these stock rx 5700 there's also a
silent BIOS which is pretty pointless
since the card is whisper quiet with its
performance BIOS setting so how much did
this new BIOS actually affect
performance let's take a look at the
5600 xD pulse from sapphire because
remember this is a pre overclocked GPU
but right now it is running at those
speeds that I just showed you can
actually see that in these games there's
a pretty significant boost in frame
rates but right across every title we
tested the performance increase was
somewhere between 12% all the way up to
20% depending on how well the game
reacted to those clock speeds that
really changed the arcs 5600 XTS outlook
however there is one little issue you
see the new BIOS was rolled out at the
very last moment and so the first batch
of shipments to retailers won't have
them installed and that's messed up
because buyers will have to find a new
BIOS and the updating tool from their
respective manufacturers website and
flashier themselves so if you have an
arc 5600 XD it's out of the box
performance won't be anywhere closer to
what you're gonna be seeing in the
benchmarks and that kind of sucks but
it's great to see what a BIOS update can
do to the performance but this almost
feels like a bit of a bait-and-switch by
AMD I mean it's great to see or greatest
show awesome results and reviews but you
guys won't be able to
those numbers without jumping through a
few hoops first not only that but it's
impossible to figure out if a card has
an updated bios until you get it home
and run amy's update tool this could be
a huge mess guys and I'm hoping AMD and
their partners make this process very
clear speaking of their partners let's
quickly take a look at the sapphire
pulse 5600 XD basically it looks like
all other pulse GPUs and that means it
has two large fans and a super compact
heatsink it's only ten inches long and
takes up two slots so nothing extreme
here I love the fact that sapphire
doesn't feel like they need the biggest
GPU on the block to look cool this thing
is clean good-looking and it should fit
into most compact cases without any
problems there's even a backplate to
complete the overall look and cut into
that is a small bio switch that I talked
about before for those of you wondering
the position closest to the i/o
connectors has the performance BIOS
which is what we use for testing while
the position towards the power input
holds a silent profile that one has
lower clock speeds reduced fan speeds
and runs at minimal power envelope ask
for power input there's an 8-pin
connector and that's about it but
anyways let's move on to the results for
this test I'll be using the RT X 2016
founders Edition the asus gtx 660ti OC
EVGA gtx 1660 super black gaming a
sapphire ARC's 5700 pulse overclocked or
OC and finally the arcs 5600 XD pulse
meanwhile this is the rest of
benchmarking setup asked for the results
let's get me soft with call of duty and
right away the RX 5600 xt is absolutely
dominating the RT x 2060 and almost
comes close to the arcs 3702 in csgo the
Nvidia cards do come out on top
especially with their 1% lows but it
should be noted we were experiencing
some CP bottlenecking here even though
the AMD GPUs have better overall
averages I'd actually choose an Nvidia
card for fortnight's since they deliver
a much smoother experience Jedi Order
shows what's really amazing about the
5600 XD it's almost able to match the
arcs 5700 in many cases outer worlds
really seems to favor Nvidia cards when
it comes to averages but the arcs 5600
XT delivers a much more playable
experience without constant suffering
especially when compared to the GTX 1660
cards in overwatch were back again to
arks 5600 xD domination where it clearly
beats the Arctic's 2060 and leaves the
GTX 1660 super in the dust Rainbow six
siege is one game that actually benefits
from the arts fifty-seven hundred eight
gigabytes of memory especially with the
HD texture pack but the Ark's 5600 xt is
still super competitive against the RT x
2060 the fact we got Red Dead Redemption
running at all his a miracle guys but
here the 5600 XT is right where we would
expect it to be as for Tomb Raider yeah
the Ark's 5600 xt is leading the r-tx
2016 again but moving on to Warhammer 2
and it's pretty evident that this is a
tough game on any system V 5600 XT
really struggles to compete on one
percent lows but overall frame rates are
pretty good and guess what we're back at
with our charts guys that's right
witcher 3 and it's here mostly as a
reminder to check out the awesome series
and to go back and enjoy this amazing
game now you can also be confident that
the RX 5600 xt is more than good enough
to play the game as well and finally
we're on to power consumption and i have
to admit even with the higher clock
speeds the 5600 xt manages to be pretty
efficient GPA when compared to the r TX
2060 the problem with that card is all
the extra die space used for ray tracing
and AI components that ends up having a
negative impact on efficiency but
honestly it looks like we might have a
low leakage core on our 5600 xt but
we'll only be able to confirm that with
more samples either way I think this is
a huge win for AMD since they've
struggled to compete with in a video
from a performance per watt standpoint
but now they won big in almost every way
well guys
AMD did it again with the 5600 XT now
sure the last-minute change didn't allow
us to run all the benchmarks that we
wanted to and I'm sure it's gonna run or
cause a lot of issues for buyers
who'd have to go through the process of
updating the BIOS to get expected
performance but I have to say that a
$290 this GPU is really really good
because even at the performance setting
it runs super quiet super efficient and
it offers tons of performance at 1080p
now NVIDIA did try to compete by
lowering the price of the r-tx 2060 to
$300 but he
mine the dents the founders edition and
it suspiciously sold out so even if you
were to find one at that price point
it's really difficult for me to
recommend that GPU over something like
this
so here's a deal plain and simple if you
want an awesome car for 1080p gaming and
you can afford it the rx 5600 xt is a
massive improvement over the gtx 1660
super in some cases it almost hits rx
5700 performance levels although that
causes some problems for the 5700 but
that cards extra memory can come in
handy for some games sure they took a
while to release this thing but right
now I feel like they did a really good
job for gamers who can actually buy this
thing at a really affordable price point
and I can't wait to see what they have
planned out for the rest of 2020 so
that's it for me thank you so much for
watching make sure to check out some
relevant content over here subscribe hit
that notification bell and I'll talk to
you guys in the next one